Concorde, the name recalls a distant era
when air travel was more like this-
Welcome aboard the spacious cabin.
Than this.
Oh my .
Someone help, this guy's crazy!
Almost two decades
after the Concorde's last
supersonic leap across the ocean,
Concorde nostalgia suddenly
seems in full swing.
All chairs will have tray
tables, not just first class.
I feel like I'm flying on the Concorde.
You can leave any time.
Meanwhile, a new generation
of companies is promising
to bring supersonic jets
back to an airport near you
by as soon as the end of this decade,
but can any of these
companies successfully pick up
where the failed Concorde left off?
So the Concorde operated
in the North Atlantic.
It was primarily Paris and London
to New York and Washington.
And we're now supersonic.
That's 11 minutes after takeoff.
It's always exciting flying supersonic,
and it's always exciting
to get to New York
before you've left.
There was a large measure
of style and panache,
and it wasn't the world's most
comfortable cabin or seat,
compared to what you would
get on a private jet today,
but it was also the bragging rights
of how fast you could do
a day trip, if you wanted.
Concorde has crossed the
Atlantic in 3.5 hours.
First, best, and fastest.
It just never became a
product for the masses,
and part of that was just the fuel cost.
These engines were engineering marvels,
but at the same time, just
completely fuel inefficient,
in terms of what they had to do.
After nearly three decades in service,
the Concorde was retired in
2003, due to rising costs,
weakening demand for
air travel after 9/11,
and a dampened safety reputation,
following a fatal crash in 2000.
Once at the bleeding edge
of aviation technology,
the legendary plane for the
elite had become a relic,
destined for museums and exhibitions.
Today, whether you're paying
to ride back here or up here,
you'll arrive at about the same time,
and that's because aircraft manufacturers
and airlines have spent the
past half-century focusing
on things like efficiency,
safety, and cabin comforts,
rather than raw speed.
But after almost two decades
since Concorde's demise,
speed may be making a comeback.
There is venture capital
money and investors
that are willing to bet
that this could work.
Secondly, there's
technology available today
that was never, ever
contemplated in the 1960s.
You can model so many
things with computers,
and the new materials, carbon composites,
all those things are coming together
so that you have some
technically minded people saying,
"Why shouldn't this happen?"
When Concorde shut down
about 20 years ago,
there was really no plan to
pick up where it left off,
and so that's what we're doing at Boom.
We're building high-speed travel
that can be available to
more people than ever before.
Boom is just one of a
number of young companies
that have snatched up the
brightest aerospace engineers
for the task of designing a new generation
of supersonic aircraft.
Every airplane looks good on paper,
but when you go from a paper
design to a physical airplane
that you're gonna put a human
life in and then go fly,
you have to solve thousands
of problems along the way,
but it's not inventing new science
and it's not inventing new technology.
Boom has been developing
an experimental supersonic
jet called the XB-1,
which, if successful, will be-
The first independently
developed supersonic jet ever.
With a name that hearkens back
to the original supersonic jet, the X-1,
the XB-1 will be used to test
and refine the engineering
that will ultimately lead to a
100-seat jet called overture.
It's more like a Concorde
2.0, and if all goes well-
We'll be carrying our first passengers
by the end of the decade.
But building a commercial plane
that can break the sound barrier
is old news at this point.
I think Google could probably go build
a supersonic business jet
in pretty short order
if they wanted to, one,
not to sell it, but just to do it.
It's just gotta be an economical product.
You can't just do it as a vanity thing.
The first commercial
supersonic experiments
in the 1960s were essentially
that, vanity projects.
The jointly built British and French jet,
literally a concord between
nations, and rival prototypes
from the Soviets and the
Americans were developed
during the same Cold War technology race
that landed humans on the moon.
National prestige outweighed
concerns about profitability,
at least for a little while.
What about the potential
market for Concorde?
What's the lowest they could be sold
and, perhaps, the highest?
If we sold 50 or less,
I should be a very disappointed man.
Disappointed indeed, though it started out
with over 100 pre-orders.
The jet's problematic
economics quickly brought
that number down to just 14,
delivered to the national airlines
of the countries that built it.
But the next generation of
supersonics are being designed
mostly by private companies,
where market viability isn't
merely an afterthought, it's paramount.
Just as Concorde retired in '03,
there's been a 2.5-fold increase
in international travel,
and that creates a lot more
markets for supersonic.
And when you put together
all the new technology,
aerodynamics, materials, propulsion,
you can now build an aircraft
that's significantly more
efficient than Concorde,
which means it can be available
to tens of millions of people
at fares like what you'd
pay in business class today,
instead of the the Forex first class
that had to be charged on Concorde.
So far, Boom's bold
aspirations have already caught
the attention of a handful of airlines
that have placed small pre-orders
for the company's Overture jet,
but whether these early votes
of confidence will translate
into success depends
on the final economics.
Another eager startup
taking a different approach
to the new supersonic
race is Spike Aerospace,
which is developing the S-512,
an 18-passenger aircraft targeted
at the nearly $30 billion
private business jet market.
Like Boom, though, one of
Spike's long-term goals is
to eventually expand supersonic travel
beyond the realm of elite luxury.
We'd looked back to the 90s,
when they first had flat-screen TVs.
They were $25,000 a screen.
Nobody could afford it.
Joe Public couldn't afford it.
It's only for the super rich,
but now, flat-screen TVs are all $200,
and the same thing's gonna
happen to supersonic flight.
Yes, initially, it probably
will be for business travelers
and the rich folks.
There is a demand, they have a need,
but can afford to fly it.
As we recover cost
and research and development
and technologies,
we'll be able to offer that
same supersonic flight service
to the general public.
I don't know that it'll be
as cheap as economy flights,
but it'll be affordable,
or more affordable
than it will be initially.
Before these next-generation
supersonics can make it
to market, though, there are
other dark legacies of Concorde
that could divert a supersonic comeback.
The first is simply too loud to ignore.
What did you think about it?
Oh, it makes you jump.
It made you jump, did it?
Yes,
oh, goodness.
You frightened of it at all?
No, not exactly.
What did you think
of it, sir?
Rather slow one, I thought.
The deafening takeoff noise
and infamous sonic booms
of supersonic aircraft
crossing the sound barrier were
so disruptive that it led
to widespread backlash
and protests in the 1960s,
eventually forcing governments
to ban all supersonic flight over land,
but there's a potential
solution taking shape
that could address both the physics
and the regulation
dilemmas of the sonic boom.
X-59 is, really, a culmination
of decades of work by NASA
to try and solve the sonic boom problem,
essentially to find a
way to reduce sonic booms
such that it's not a boom anymore,
but a sound that might be
acceptable if heard every day.
To accomplish that
goal, NASA has partnered
with Lockheed Martin's
famous Skunk Works division
to develop an advanced airframe design
that can actually minimize the impact
of the sonic shockwave on the ground.
But the heart of the project is
about gauging public reaction
in order to pave the way
for new supersonic federal
and international guidelines.
Our plan is to do,
essentially, five to six tests
in various locations in the United States
to hopefully get on the order
of thousands of survey responses.
Given a sound of a certain level,
this percentage of the
population is annoyed.
So it's all about providing data
that can help the FAA and
the ICAO establish the limits
that go along with this
certification standard.
Reducing or eliminating the nuisance
of sonic booms could open
up countless new routes,
helping to make an economy of
scale for supersonic travel
that was never possible for Concorde.
But there's another drawback
of supersonic flight
that has taken on a new importance
over the past few decades,
fuel consumption and emissions.
In order to propel its 100-seat cabin
to speeds of nearly 1,400
miles per hour, Concorde burned
multiple times the amount
of fuel per passenger,
versus a typical transoceanic jet.
Given the fluctuating costs of
fuel and the growing concern
over the environmental
impacts of air travel,
it's hard to imagine a modern
carrier purchasing planes
as thirsty and messy as
the Concorde once was.
But recent technological strides may give
the supersonic startups a chance
to rectify this negative legacy, as well.
Speed is not enough.
We need to do it in an
environmentally responsible way.
And so the question really for us was
can we engineer these liquid fuels,
instead of just relying
on fossil-based fuels
that are obviously bad
for our environment?
Aerion has partnered
with Canada-based Carbon Engineering,
whose Direct Air Capture technology pulls
CO2 right out of the air,
which can then be processed
into commercial products like jet fuel.
It's still a bit
theoretical at this point,
but it would mean, essentially,
carbon-neutral high-speed flight.
So think about the only CO2
that the AS2, Aerion's airplane,
puts into the atmosphere
was first CO2 we took
out of the air to make the fuel.
So not only do we go really, really fast,
but we have no footprint
on the environment.
While all of these
supersonic startups are eager
for us to break the sound barrier again,
it's hard not to be at
least a little bit skeptical
of the projections,
given how notoriously difficult
aircraft development can be.
For instance, Boeing's
wide-body 787 Dreamliner
reportedly ran billions
of dollars over budget
and arrived to market three
years later than expected,
and that's for a jet based largely
on proven subsonic technology
and well-proven subsonic economics.
There's also the unknown
long-term impact on demand
in a post-pandemic world,
in which business or VIP travel
may be replaced more often
by a virtual meeting instead.
Then again, supersonic might
actually offer extra appeal
for travelers trying to
cut down on the time spent
in an enclosed cabin with
a bunch of other people.
The customer wants 100 things.
I think that's where the
rubber hits the road,
or whatever the cliche is.
That's where you're gonna see.
It's not can you build this plan,
but can you do it within
all these parameters
that the market is setting for you?
Another way to look at
the new supersonic race is
that it's part of a
broader vision for a future
with simply more options
for long-distance travel,
whether by supersonic, hypersonic,
or an entirely new mode,
like suborbital flights,
that hop between points on the globe.
This latest round of startups
are simply pushing us
toward that frontier.
And that might sound a
little pie-in-the-sky,
but when you're trying
to usher in a new age
of super-fast travel, it
helps to be optimistic.
We're gonna go across the Atlantic
and come home the same day.
We're gonna have more meetings in person.
It's gonna change who you
can fall in love with.
I want a world
where no relationship is ever
considered long-distance.
That's not science fiction.